arabic is according to estimates the
fifth most widely spoken language in the
world today
it serves as an official language across
the middle east and north africa even if
it is spoken in a number of different
dialects
arabic also serves as a liturgical
language within the religion of islam
being the language of the quran and thus
imbued with a lot of religious
significance
as such it is directly linked to divine
revelation and has a significant role to
play in history
muslims across the world read the quran
in arabic daily even if they don't
understand the words themselves it goes
without saying that arabic therefore has
a lot of legend associated with it
because it is the language of the quran
god's unmediated speech according to the
majority of muslims it has almost a
divine status some muslims historically
have considered arabic to be the one
language with which god communicates
with mankind and that arabic is the
language spoken by the angels in heaven
thus being somehow eternal but if we
approach things from a historical and
archaeological perspective looking at
material that we can date study and
scrutinize what picture emerges then
about the origins and development of the
arabic language
where did it come from who spoke it and
what can that tell us about the ancient
world
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
arabic is a semitic language this means
that it is closely related to other
languages in that family including
hebrew aramaic and syriac and egyptian
for example and anyone who speaks these
languages will know how many
similarities and points of overlap there
can be between them just look at a word
like salam and shalom in arabic and
hebrew for example both meaning peace so
we know that arabic comes from the
semitic family of languages and that it
developed alongside other languages in
that category but where does arabic in
particular come from well this is a
pretty difficult question to answer
because languages are always changing
and evolving
now i am not a linguist and so i am
venturing somewhat outside of my
field of knowledge here more so than i
usually am so even more so in this case
than in my other videos i highly suggest
and and recommend that you check out the
literature and the sources that i will
leave in the description for a more
proper
run through a proper studies in this
field by actual experts many have tried
to explain the origins of the arabic
language there have been many mythical
accounts for example in ibn al-khelbi
the writer of the kitab al-assam or book
of idols who we talked about in the
episode about pre-islamic arabia he
writes that it was the amalier
giants who came from babylon who first
spoke arabic and took it with them to
arabia putting aside these mythical
accounts one very pervasive theory and
widely accepted idea is that arabic
originates in southern arabia and around
modern day yemen and then it later from
that spread northward across the
peninsula
but in fact recent revolutionary
scholarship has suggested that this is
actually false indeed it seems that the
situation was instead reversed but let's
not get ahead of ourselves and back up a
little bit as i mentioned in the episode
about pre-islamic arabia and its
religious traditions we are really
witnessing a
incredibly fruitful and interesting
period in the academic study of
pre-islamic rabia or ancient arabia
generally there is huge new finds and
discoveries being made all the time
which is giving us new perspectives on
this culture and this material shows
that in ancient arabia there were a
whole host of different languages spoken
across the arabian peninsula
in no way was there a universal arabic
spoken across the region until basically
after the arrival of islam
indeed the languages that were spoken
and written in what is today yemen was
as far removed from modern arabic as
hebrew is
not only was there a myriad of different
languages spoken but also a lot of
different scripts or alphabets
some of these alphabets can be read by
scholars today while others remain
undeciphered
we have in southern arabia scripts like
sabaic and hadramitik and in northern
arabia there is the themudic languages
so themudik bc etc and then there is
also
scripts like hismaik and sapphiretic
and if we look at any of those alphabets
none of them look anything like the
arabic script that we know and love so
this is the first picture we need to
have in mind ancient arabia was a
multilingual place filled with various
languages and scripts in which those
languages were expressed but where is
our arabic then did it even exist in the
ancient world
some scholars have argued that arabic as
a language really only arrives very
shortly before the birth of islam and
the prophet muhammad but this is really
only true if we connect the arabic
language itself
specifically with the arabic script
because indeed like when we talk about
cultures or religions
languages too are always constantly
evolving it's always changing and if we
accept that less narrow view of the
arabic language
things start to open up a little bit
more and we can start to see traces of
arabic further back in history no one
language just arrives out of nowhere
completed and then just stays that way
instead languages are always
transforming reacting to other languages
interacting with neighboring ways and
finding new ways of expression
it would be foolish to expect to find
classical arabic as we know it today
back in
500 bc or whatever and the same goes for
any other language but as i said if we
accept this broader and more nuanced way
of looking at language the door opens up
a little bit more because indeed even as
far back as the second half of the first
millennium bc we find a few inscriptions
and examples of language expression that
does have strong characteristics of
arabic and which probably is an earlier
form of that very language the
difference here is that these examples
of proto-arabic are not written in the
arabic script which wasn't invented yet
but in various different alphabets it is
only when we read them out loud so to
say that we recognize its character as
being essentially an arabic or close to
arabic now interestingly all of these
examples basically of
the earliest forms or examples of arabic
do not come from southern arabia as has
been
presumed before but is that all of the
examples are from the northernmost part
of arabia in places like syria and
jordan now this makes a lot of sense of
course since arabic is so closely
related to languages like hebrew and
aramaic which were languages that were
widely spoken in that general region the
more northern parts of arabia the middle
east and the levant and so on in other
words arabic is clearly developing at
this time in a
diverse environment both culturally
religiously and linguistically and it's
developing alongside its sister
languages like hebrew and aramaic
which are very closely related to it now
this might be a good time to dispel a
very common myth that the ancient arabs
were illiterate
indeed there are thousands upon
thousands of inscriptions from this
region that shows us that
the arabs had a very high rate of
literacy especially in the northern
parts of arabia the scholar of languages
michael mcdonald writes quote literacy
seems to have been extraordinarily
widespread not only among these settled
populations but also among the nomads
indeed the scores of thousands of
graffiti on the rocks of the
syria-arabian desert suggests that it
must have been almost universal among
the latter
by the roman period it is probable that
a higher proportion of the population in
this region was functionally literate
than in any other area of the ancient
world so as i said we have a few
examples of arabic or proto-arabic from
very early on so
close to a thousand bc but it's really
only when we get much closer to the turn
of that millennium around year one
basically that we start to see a real
abundance of examples of arabic
especially in the period between the 2nd
century bc to around the 4th century a.d
there are thousands and thousands of
inscriptions in northern arabia that
contain early forms and examples of the
arabic language
most of these inscriptions are in the
safayitic and hismaic scripts which were
used primarily in southern syria jordan
and the most northern parts of modern
saudi arabia but even so the arabic we
find in these texts are sometimes a bit
different from the arabic that we know
in its classical form
these differences have led some scholars
to argue that this language shouldn't be
categorized as arabic but as one form of
the wider group known as ancient north
arabian for example one of the most
distinguishing features of arabic is its
use of the definite article al as in
al-kitab meaning the book or al-quran
meaning the quran but the majority of
sapphiretic and his make inscriptions
instead use the definite article ha
similar to in hebrew like in the
following example called li hamlet bin
salem hallest
so we can see that
the the particular character
characteristic form of arabic the
different article
doesn't really appear in most of the
inscriptions even though there are
examples of that too and this has led
some scholars to say that it shouldn't
be considered arabic but again if we
accept the less narrow view of language
and recognize that languages change and
that they are diverse and varied and
also look at all the other similarities
to arabic that we find in these
inscriptions
i think it's safe to say that this is in
some ways at least an earlier form of
that language so that's the general
picture in the earliest period arabic
appears in northern arabia written by
people who were most likely referred to
as arabs as arab either by themselves or
by others and this language was written
in various different scripts in the
region including sapphiatic hismaik and
even greek for example
sometime after this period it seems that
the arabic language started to spread
southward into the arabian peninsula
it is in the first couple of centuries
a.d that we see the first examples of
the word arab being used in southern
arabia
although at the same time there is no
evidence that the arabic language was
spoken here until really the
post-islamic period so with this general
picture in mind the natural follow-up
question is well okay the arabic
language seemed to exist in northern
arabia but when did the arabic script
appear and when did arabic the language
take the form that we know it as today
to answer those questions it's time to
talk about one of the most important
factors in the development of the arabic
language
that is the nabateans
the nabatean kingdom was an arab state
that ruled in northern arabia and the
southern levant from the 3rd century bc
to the 1st century a.d when it was
annexed by the romans
the nebateans were a rich and
flourishing culture that built
magnificent cities and monuments
they are most famous for their capital
city petra in modern day jordan which
was a major point in trade routes across
the middle east in antiquity
now the nebatean spoke arabic as their
everyday language the kind of arabic
that we can see in the ancient
inscriptions which have talked about
varied as it was
but for all their official documents and
business correspondences they used
aramaic the kind of lingua franca of the
region at the time and wrote this
aramaic in a unique script now what
happens here is that we see over the
course of time how the nabataean script
primarily used to write aramaic
gradually started to be used to write
arabic
after the nabateans were conquered by
the romans and their kingdom ended as
such people still continue to write in
the inhabitant script
and when we look at this script
especially as it develops and changes
during the first couple of centuries a.d
we see a script that really start to
resemble the later arabic script take a
look at these nebatean inscriptions from
the early 4th century for example
and once we move even further forward
into history we can see how the evolving
nabataean script not only is used
further south in arabia it is spreading
as his script used to write it's
becoming more popular across the
peninsula but also how it becomes a
script for writing the arabic language
proper and that by around the late 5th
century or early 6th century we finally
have examples of the arabic that we all
know so well both in style and in script
there is for example the famous hard on
inscription from 568 a.d
but notice how late this is in history
by the time we get a complete arabic
language and script we are only about a
century before the life of the prophet
muhammad now that isn't to say that
arabic didn't exist prior to this as we
have seen we have seen that arabic did
exist but that it evolved and changed
and existed in various different forms
it is really only this form of the
language that had developed by the early
6th century that was later canonized
into official classical arabic but given
the fact that we've seen arabic and the
language evolved so much over the
centuries and the millennia how come
that this particular form was the one
that survived
and this is of course where the religion
of islam makes its very dramatic
entrance as we all know the quran is in
arabic
being god's word and divine revelation
according to muslims its contents had
immediate sacred status
it was important for reciters and
readers of the quran to be able to
pronounce and understand it properly and
to safeguard the language that it
contains
it is for this reason that we see
grammarians in the post-islamic period
starting to create a system of grammar
linguistic rules and other technical
aspects of the language
when it comes to the arabic script in
particular the situation is similar the
earliest manuscripts of the quran did
not contain any short vowels it
basically only had consonants the short
vowels of the arabic language known as
fatha kasra and dhamma and corresponds
to the sounds
respectively
was developed in the centuries after the
quran was written down or had been
revealed in order to fix its
pronunciation and meaning since small
vowel differences can change the meaning
of words and whole sentences so in a lot
of ways the quran is the primary source
for the classical arabic language it was
the quran and its language that
determined what became official arabic
and has served as its kind of gold
standard ever since through the quran
the post-islamic arabs took a language
that was diverse and evolving and
created a system of grammar that remains
basically identical today anyone who
understands standard arabic or fusha can
pick up the quran and read it without
any major things like this so the
arrival of the religion of islam played
a central and important role in the
development of the arabic language which
is also what justifies me making a video
about it on this channel we can also of
course see how this event
the prophet muhammad and the revelation
of the quran
affected the geographical spread of the
language as well
it seems that it was only after the
prophet muhammad and his successors had
unified arabia into a
unified state that we see the arabic
language being adopted universally
across the peninsula it may even be
after this fact that the whole identity
of arab became a universal point of
identification for people in this region
and of course with the later conquests
of the rashidun and umayyad caliphates
the geographical spread of arabic became
even more significant it is said that it
was the umayyad caliph abdul malik who
made arabic the official language of the
empire thus beginning the process that
created the situation as it stands today
with arabic being spoken as a primary
language across the middle east north
africa and in the middle ages in
southern spain but despite the
systematization of the arabic language
and its script as well as its official
use across the empire it seems that some
of the native languages and scripts that
were used in pre-islamic periods
in the
in arabia continued to exist and perhaps
also be used
for a while afterwards a couple of
centuries in the post-islamic period
thus even though the quranic arabic
became widespread as an official arabic
the assimilation was a gradual one even
in the heart of the peninsula of course
the linguistic map is diverse today just
as it was in antiquity and arabic as
most of you probably know is spoken in a
variety of different dialects across the
arabic speaking world
to the point that a person from iraq
often has a very hard time understanding
someone from morocco and vice versa but
the official arabic of the quran the
liturgical language of islam and
official language of the early
caliphates remain in what is known as
fusha or standard arabic
this is a form of the language that
basically everyone learns in school at
least in arabic speaking countries
some newspapers use fosa in in their in
their papers poetry is written in it and
some news channels like al jazeera also
use it but it's never really spoken in
everyday conversation still the fact
that fusa has survived even to this day
even though its modern standard arabic
form has a lot of loan words and and
innovations to it the core aspect of
language survives pretty much intact
which shows you the central importance
and role played by the quran and the
religion of islam for the general
development of the whole arabic language
in this episode we have gone on a
journey from antiquity up until the
modern day
we have seen how the arabic language
started in the northern parts of arabia
probably been spoken here and also
written in various different alphabets
and scripts including hismaik safayitik
and even scripts like the greeks script
it then spread further south into the
arabian peninsula as far as places like
hijaz and gradually became more
widespread in the region and just more
popular as a language we also saw how
the nabataean kingdom and their
official script that was used to write
administrative
documents in aramaic gradually became
used to write the arabic language even
after the nebatean kingdom ended and
that as it developed over the first few
centuries a.d
this script eventually became what we
know as the arabic script today finally
we saw that by the 6th century the final
quote-unquote form of arabic had
developed a form of arabic that was
expressed in the sacred scripture of
islam and thus canonized and you could
say frozen into its classical form even
if it always continues to evolve of
course clearly then arabic is a language
that has a long and deep history its
mysterious yet fascinating origins can
help us better appreciate the ways that
it persists even today remaining one of
the most widely spoken and significant
languages in the world i hope you like
this video if you want to support this
channel and its attempts to give you
free and scholarly uh content about the
world's different religious traditions
you can support us on patreon through a
monthly donation or three one-time
donation on paypal you are also free of
course to subscribe like and leave a
comment
and i will see you next time
[Music]
you